so joining me now is our two
pennsylvania voters
josie ramos is a trump supporter from
carbon county
she's a part-time teacher she worked
about 15 years ago for
senator santorum her husband runs
latinos for trump
in their area and owen dempsey a biden
supporter from delaware county he's a
novelist and former teacher
um and he is joining us tonight as well
um owen let me start with you
uh you say that you are you were born in
ireland
uh and that you became a citizen because
you wanted to vote against president
trump is that right
it is correct i've been living here
since 2008 and
i was on a green card and it was
the motivating factor was this election
coming up i
obviously you know i felt like a bit
like the boston tea party
tax rep taxation without representation
wasn't sitting too well with me either
but uh the major factor me becoming a us
citizen was in order to vote in this
election yes
so josie let me bring you in here you
say that
you spent a lot of time talking to
voters in pennsylvania
and you think that the state or at least
your area is
being somewhat misread by these polls
i do um i'm originally from carbon
county but i do a lot of work
in allentown which is the third largest
city in pennsylvania
uh allentown is extremely liberal
a lot a high minority population who is
used to
having having been many years on
government assistance
and the welfare and the whole poverty
cycle and what we're seeing
which is very exciting during this
campaign in the last couple months are
people coming in
to talk with me or other people that i
know are family members or neighbors
in the city saying you know i'm
researching for myself and i'm
finding out that the party that i've
been voting for has been duping me all
my life
i'm pro-life i mean my community and
there's a
large hispanic and black community in
allentown
is is largely pro-life um
you know faith guides the family as well
they're starting to see that um
you know being on government assistance
requires them to have split families
in order to have a higher government
assistant check and they're tired of
that they want
families they want fathers in their
family and they're saying the other side
is not giving that to me and so we're
seeing a lot of people
asking questions researching for
themselves my community
coming in to kind of confirm those
answers and changing their parties
changing affiliation interesting uh owen
obviously the economy has been through a
very tough time with covid
and there have there's been some
pushback against the governor in
pennsylvania for not
opening things up not letting you know
restaurants and and gyms and all of
these places really get back to their
full capacity
um what do you say about that and does
that influence your vote at all
um well i think that's trying to restart
the economy without
tr without effectively dealing with the
virus is a waste of time i like
i i think the virus is so important in
our lives today it's completely
dominating our lives at the moment the
225
000 americans have died millions of
people infected
and it's only getting worse the
situation is getting i think the record
for the amount of cases in one day was
this week
now um president trump has tried to
blame the
governors on this and blaming each
individual governors and
breaking things into red states and blue
states whereas it's his responsibility
for the country of the united states of
america
as far as governor wolf's concerned he's
been very good i thought he's
he's our rates haven't been overly bad
of course
with like a lot of things in the last
week or so they have gone up but he's
been he's given a lot of information
um and i i'm quite grateful for that i
must say
okay owen uh and josie thank you both
very much
good to have both of you with us tonight
share your viewpoints